what is up everybody my name is Heath
Adams and I welcome you to this course
called Linux for ethical hackers so in
this course we're going to be covering a
lot of things we're really going to be
going and hammering down on the terminal
and the command line and if you've never
learned Linux before this is a really
great start for you especially if you're
interested in becoming ethical hacker or
a penetration tester so enough of my
face let's go ahead and just dive right
in
alright everyone welcome to this course
titled Linux for ethical hackers before
we get started I'd like to do a little
who am I so my name is Heath Adams I
also go by the cyber mentor I am a
husband first a hacker a military
veteran gamer sports fan and animal dad
I am a former accountant turned security
geek so I've been in cybersecurity about
three years now and before that I was an
accountant hated it picked that bad
field for all the wrong reasons so once
I went into IT and cybersecurity I never
looked back and I've never been happier
on the day-to-day I am a senior security
engineer I'm also a business owner at
TCM security so before that I was a
senior penetration tester doing
penetration testing and ethical hacking
I branched out and started my own
business focusing on ethical hacking
training and student development so now
I'm doing that full-time along with a
job as a senior security engineer okay
so let's go ahead and talk about what
we'll learn in this course so this
course is going to be all hands-on
besides this little introduction here
you're not going to see a lot of
PowerPoint besides quick overview of
what the course or the video that you're
about to see has coming so 95% hands-on
course I will not kill you with
PowerPoint that's not my goal we're
going to be focusing on Kali Linux this
entire course and really learning Linux
and learning Linux for the purpose of
becoming ethical hackers so we're going
to install VMware which is a virtualized
software virtualization software
then we're gonna run Kali Linux inside
of VMware after that I'm gonna give you
a overview of Kali Linux show you some
of the common tools what it can do why
it's awesome and then we're gonna do a
deep dive into the terminal so what that
means is we're going to be hands-on
doing commands and learning Linux so
we'll be running navigating the
filesystem so how to get around in the
filesystem from the terminal will learn
about users and privileges how to add
users how to what kind of privileges and
permissions are there what important
files exist regarding those we're gonna
talk about common Network commands so if
you want to be a pentester ethical
hacker you need to know networking at
least had a basic minimum so we'll talk
about those common network commands that
you should know how to run them what
they do we'll talk about viewing
creating and editing files that's
obviously important if you want to
create a quick file or edit a file from
the command-line how you can do that
we'll talk about starting and stopping
services such as a web server SSH sequel
database etc we're going to talk about
how to install updates how to install
tools and how to update those tools and
then lastly we're going to put
everything we learned together and do
some scripting in bash so we're going to
write a basic bash script and then we'll
improve upon it and then I'll show you
some for loops some other logical
scripting ideas and then we'll kind of
put that together and hopefully come to
a nice completion when it's all said and
done so with all this being said I am
excited to have you in the course with
me I look forward to teaching you and
let's go ahead and start with installing
VMware alright the first thing that
we're going to need to do is to install
software called VMware Workstation
Player now we have two ways to run Kali
Linux we can either run Kali Linux
through a virtual machine or we can
stall it as an operating system on a
hard drive for this course and this
lesson we're going to be using a virtual
machine and preferably we're going to be
using VMware Workstation player
I'm going to show you how to install
VMware Workstation player and I'll show
you some of the alternatives to it as
well so let's go ahead and dive right in
okay so if you go out to the interweb
and you go to Google and you type in
VMware Workstation player the first
thing that will come up for you is this
download VMware Workstation player link
you're going to go ahead and just click
on this and now I also want to introduce
alternatives so there is a another
software platform called Oracle
VirtualBox and you will be able to
install either my preference and the
course that's going to be taught the
rest of the way through is going to be
in VMware Workstation pro but we will
use player for the install you'll be
able to follow along with player you'll
also be able to follow along with Oracle
VirtualBox if you so choose but we will
not be showing that installation another
thing that should be noted
is there is this comparison page here
and I will be using VMware Workstation
Pro there's a nice little checklist here
that shows what Pro can do versus player
it has a lot of the same features here
some of the nice things is running
multiple VMs at once you can technically
do that with VMware Workstation player
there's workarounds for it but to have
it in a single tabbed interface it's
very very nice you see here the drag
will tabbed interface that's another
feature snapshots so basically making a
backup of your machine all included in
workstation Pro so if you have some
money to shell out and this is something
that you are interested in doing long
term it may be worth looking into a
workstation Pro license but by all means
you can get away with a workstation
Player installation and that's exactly
what we're going to do so let's go back
to the first tab here and you can see it
says try a VMware Workstation player
we're just going to scroll down and this
install and everything is going to be
running on top of windows for me if
you're installing for Linux that's fine
as well just follow your instructions
for your respective OS
go ahead and select download now I'm
gonna save the file okay it downloaded
I'm gonna hit run it's going to ask if
we want to accept the changes yes okay
now we're going to hit next we'll accept
the license agreement and possibly give
away our first board I'm gonna go ahead
and check yes for the enhanced keyboard
driver we don't need to check for a
product update we don't need to join the
VMware customer experience improvement
we'll hit next on that you can leave
both of these checked or check to your
preference and then hit install and
while this is installing I can actually
show you what VMware pro looks like this
is a pro instance running here you can
see that I have the tabs and there
draggable as it was notated in that that
differential spreadsheet that you saw
and I've got a Kali instance running
that's actually my main Kali machine
I've got Windows 10 running here and
this is all actually sitting on top of a
real Windows 10 machine as well so we're
just installing workstation Player I'm
going to run it a VM inside of the VM so
it's gonna be a little bit of VM ception
here and then we're just gonna hit
finish and then we are going to restart
this machine as it needs a reboot real
quick okay now we are restarted and
we're back to our desktop here you can
see that VMware Workstation player has
been added to the desktop let's just go
ahead and double click that to open it
and we're going to choose to use VMware
Workstation 15 player for free for
non-commercial use if we wanted the Pro
Edition we would enter in our access key
here or license key and continue on with
the Pro Edition
and now we will use the finish button
here and will be brought to our VMware
Workstation 15 player so you can see
here that it's a much much different
view it's very very basic we have the
option to open a VM here and we'll have
the one VM stored in this tab that we
can open up and that'll be it
there are ways around running multiple
VMs at the same time but if you're
looking to build a fluid lab out and
have multiple VMs running similar to
what I have here having the VMware Pro
again it does have its benefits here so
you can see this is a much much
different look this is very generic as
we we can see here so from here what
we're gonna do is we're gonna go ahead
and stop in the next video we are going
to focus on downloading Kali Linux and
we'll talk about what Kali Linux is and
some of its features as well so I'll
catch you over in the next video all
right now let's move on to installing
Kali Linux in our VMware software ok so
picking up where we left off we had just
installed VMware Workstation 15 Player
and now we need a VM to actually be able
to play with it so this whole course is
going to be based on Kali Linux if we
open up a internet browser here I've got
a few tabs already opened so what I want
you to do is go ahead and go out to
Google and just type in Kali ka Li Linux
download and leave it here what we're
gonna do as well is I want to talk just
a quick second about what Kali Linux is
so Kali Linux is a debian-based Linux OS
so it's based on pen testing tools and
it's made for pen testers so what it
does is it comes pre-loaded with a bunch
of penetration testing tools a tool kit
if you'll call it and it is just made
for people who are looking to do pen
testing so this is provided by offensive
six
if you come to Cali org and you look at
the about us it provides a little bit of
information about who the core
developers were and some of the
moderators but basically what it is is
it followed up a tool called or a
distribution called backtrack so the new
the new tool is Kali Linux now there are
alternatives out there one of the
alternatives right now is called parrot
so if you go to parent org and you look
into what is parent you can see that
they have different distributions and
they talk about why parrot is different
but they do have a pen test distribution
here so for this course we're going to
be using Kali Linux but I always do like
to introduce the alternatives Kali Linux
is probably more popular at this point
parrot OS is kind of on the newer side
some people are starting to get behind
it and liking it but I would say Kali
still dominates the third option is that
you set up your own distribution so you
have an OS that you like and then you
install the tools on the OS that you
like and you have your own custom build
so some people feel like you know Kali
or an even parrot they come with a bunch
of tools that they'll never need so
their system's bloated and they really
just have a set amount of tools that
they like and if there's a tool that
they want to add into the system then
they'll download that on their own they
don't want to have a ton of bloatware
coming with their system but with my
experience in the industry mostly
everybody that I've worked with is using
Kali Linux some people are doing their
own builds especially on like the web
app pen testing side and then now parrot
is kind of that up-and-coming OS that
some people are transitioning to but it
is predominantly Kali Linux so that is
why we're doing this course in Kali
Linux and I feel like it's the best
option for us
to learn some just some basic Linux
skills and learn it in the OS that is
the most dominant in the industry right
now so let's go ahead and go back to
that kali linux download
while this link has been clicked on do
not let it fool you were actually not
clicking on the official Kali Linux
downloads page we're gonna scroll down a
little bit I want to go to the kali
linux custom image downloads page and
i'll show you why here so this is that
offensive - security comm make sure
that's the one you're following along
with and if you scroll down just a bit
you see that they're providing us VMware
images in VirtualBox images so remember
when I told you that VirtualBox was an
option if you chose that option here you
go right here you'll click on this tab
and you will download the VirtualBox
image now what we're gonna be doing is
we're going to be running Kali Linux VM
ware 64-bit and we're going to download
the 7-zip right here you also have the
option to download a torrent if you'd
like the file size is going to be a 2.4
gigs so it might take you a minute
depending on your your speed of your
internet and they also provide a shot
256 um if you want to check the a file
when you download it so I'm gonna go
ahead and just hit download on this and
I'm gonna save it and I will come back
as soon as this file is finished
downloading okay so my file has finished
downloading I'm going to navigate to the
folder where it has downloaded to which
is the Downloads folder and you can see
here that is a 7-zip file so my
installation by default does not have
7-zip if you do not have 7-zip either we
can go ahead and download that together
so if you go out to Google and you just
type in 7-zip the first thing that comes
up is seven - zip org you'll see a
download tab here just go ahead and
click on that link and go ahead and
download the executable for your
respective operating system so for me
I'm gonna be downloading the 64-bit
Windows version here and I'm going to
save I'm gonna hit run say yes I'm going
to go ahead and install to the default
directory okay now that's installed
let's go back to our folder and let's
select that we open with 7-zip here
okay now
you can drag and drop we can so all I'm
doing is dragging and dropping I'm
putting it in the Downloads folder you
don't have to do that you can drag it
and put it in a location that you would
prefer this is going to extract I
believe at a larger file size than just
the 2.5 gigs that we downloaded or 2.4
gig so make sure that you have file
space where you're gonna put this so I'm
gonna go ahead and let this finish and
then I will be right back ok so I
successfully unzip this file and just
for the record if we hover over it you
can see that it actually extracted to be
10 point 4 gigabytes so let's make sure
that wherever you extract it to you have
the 10 point 4 gigabytes in order to
successfully complete the extraction so
from here let's go ahead and open up our
vmware player and we're going to go to
player up in the left hand corner we're
gonna select file and then we're going
to select open and then we're going to
go to downloads and we're gonna go into
our kali linux folder here and or
wherever you put it if you didn't put it
in the downloads folder and then just
select the one item that should be here
it's a little 4 kilobyte file and what
this does for us is it automatically has
a build that's just ready to go so this
is really awesome we don't have to
download the image itself and then
install it and then pick all the
features no this is just ready to go for
us so we can also come down here and
select edit virtual machine settings and
there are a couple features here so
depending on the amount of memory that
you have on your machine so right now
this is sitting at two gigs of ram
that's fine if you want it to run faster
i recommend going somewhere between 4
and 8 obviously the more ram you give it
the the better it's gonna perform but if
you're running on a gigs of ram for your
machine really not going to do well for
you
my recommendation is no more than a
fourth so if you're running on six
and maybe give this for you could really
try pushing it up to eight but I am
running on 32 right now so I could crank
this up to eight by my role here but
just for working with you and following
along I'm gonna set this to two and then
we're going to perform in two that way
that we are working at the same speeds
across the board another thing that we
need to note is the network adapter by
default it's set to NAT we're gonna go
ahead and just leave it at NAT here
yours may come set to bridge if for some
reason it's set to bridge you can try
that but my default preference is NAT so
let's go ahead and just hit OK okay and
now we're just gonna hit play virtual
machine and a little side note I am
actually now on my OS I'm running on my
my Windows OS as opposed to just running
inside the VM if I was running a VM
inside of the VM I would have a lot of
issues degradation etc so now I've
actually moved out of the VM and have
this running and player on my Windows OS
okay and then when we get this pop up
here go ahead and just say I copied it
and this will start the machine and you
can see the other vmware player back
here it's going to go ahead and directly
just start loading up here and we get to
this screen so we click in and if we try
to just enter in our username password
our username by default is going to be
root our password is going to be root
backwards so t0 R and then hit enter now
we can make this full screen over here
by clicking this button and we'll enter
into full screen mode we are now
successfully logged into our Kali Linux
machine we've installed it successfully
and now we are ready to start learning
so that's it for this video in the next
video what we're going to be doing is
we're going to cover some of the tools
and features of Kali Linux and we'll
start talking about what it's capable of
and then we'll dive right into the
terminal after that and start learning
some so command line and some useful
tools with Linux so I will catch you
guys in the next video all right now
let's take a look around kali linux and
just see what it has to offer us in
terms of tools design etc so let's dive
right in ok so we're at our desktop here
inside of kali linux now you see the
kali linux logo you see there's a couple
of things on the desktop you don't have
to worry about these these are just from
vmware themselves put on your desktop if
you install this as an actual OS this
will not be here so when we talk about
navigating around kali linux there's a
couple of places that we can look if we
look right away you can see on the left
hand side over here we've got a
favorites bar so we've got our folders
so if we click on the folders or our
files we can navigate around this feels
like any other machine right we have our
documents downloads music pictures if
you're a Windows user or Mac user
whatever this feels pretty common so
this is a GUI or a graphical user
interface way
of interacting with the folders as you
move on and we move on in this course
we're going to be living in the terminal
so the terminal is right here if you
click on the terminal this is something
similar to your command line so from
here we can actually navigate to all
these folders here and we can put files
in there take files out anything that we
can do in a graphic point of view we can
also do from this command line point of
view as well so as we learn we're gonna
get a little less relying on the
graphical interface and more on the
terminal side of things however do know
that there are ways to do a lot of
things from a graphical side if you
still need that that interaction with
the machine and you don't want to be
completely keyboard oriented there are
also tools on the side over here if we
look we've got a leaf pad so leaf pad is
just like a notepad right or you know
just your notebook here you can take
some quick notes save it out should be
pretty familiar for you as well so
they've got Firefox it used to be called
iceweasel
and that's just your web browser down
here are some of the tools that you may
use now burp suite is a very popular
tool for web application penetration
testing we're not gonna be getting into
any of these tools at the moment but I
will cover what a couple of them do so
again burp Suites a web application
penetration testing tool if you ever get
into web app or if you even get into
some basic pen testing chances are
you're gonna start using burp suite on a
pretty regular basis over here is Zen
map now this is the graphical version of
a tool called nmap and you will be using
an map pretty religiously when you're
doing pen testing so if you like a
visual view of doing scanning so nmap is
a network mapper it allows you to scan
machines for open ports and for
vulnerabilities so if you want that in a
more of a visual type of view a
graphical interface type view then you
have Zen map as a
feature this little guy down here is
Metasploit now Metasploit is a tool that
can be taught all these are tools that
can be taught in deep deep lessons all
by themselves not to make that
intimidating for you at all just know
that that's how robust this is we're
looking at three tools right here and
they're all very very powerful and this
isn't even the half of it or the quarter
of what kali linux has to offer so
Metasploit you may have heard of it if
you've heard of anything in pen testing
it is a framework that does just a
little bit of everything so a lot of pen
testers live and die by this it's a
fantastic tool in my opinion and you're
going to get very very intimate with it
very very quick if you do move into pen
testing down here is a tool called
cherry tree and that's pretty much where
I'm gonna stop we've got multi go in
kismet these are just this is wireless
base and this one here is is information
gallery base but cherry tree is another
useful one if we open that up this is
actually another note keeping tool like
I showed you leafpad leave paths just
for quick little one-offs cherry tree is
more of note keeping as a whole so
you've got nodes that you can add so you
can add a node here and just say say
you're following along and you want to
add notes you can say Linux you know and
then you have a node you can add all of
your notes in here and then you can
actually add children nodes as well so
maybe there's a command that you want to
add in so say we're covering commands
and you want to write all the commands
in about Linux down here you could do
that as well and then save this out a
nice thing too is that you can take
screenshots and put them in here and
exports really nice and this is gonna be
very very useful for anything in your
career but when it comes to pen testing
there are so many tools so many commands
that I think it is incredibly important
to be able to take notes and Cherry Tree
is built in already personally I use
what used to be in
Linux which is a tool called I keep note
but Cherrytree is a great alternative as
well so either of them would work and is
highly recommended by me that you use
some sort of note keeping tool as you go
through your courses and get better as a
pen tester so I'm going to close out of
this here and I want to show you a
couple more things you have a feature
here where you can show all of your
applications so if you click on that
it'll bring up all the applications
including the ones that are grouped down
here another way to do this is if we
come up into applications at the top you
can see that everything is grouped
really nice for you so it goes through
the steps of penetration testing and
let's say that like hey I'm gathering
information on a client ok well here are
some of the built-in tools for
information gathering right here say you
want to do a wireless assessment and do
you want to do that those sorts of
attacks you've got all these wireless
tools built in for you right here now
chances are you're gonna be running
these tools from the command-line so
again you know you don't want to get too
hung up on the graphical side of things
as you may not always have access to
that either but it's important to know
what tools that you have in front of you
and there are even tools like Wireshark
in here so very very useful pretty much
a little bit of everything that you can
imagine so just you know take some time
and go through the tools and if you're
becoming a pen tester you're working on
it you know just just you know look at a
tool and do some research on it say you
want to know what this Mac changer is it
might be obvious it might not be obvious
right so maybe you go google what Mac
changer does how to use it what the
syntax is and then you play around with
that take a new tool every day figure
out something that you can do with it
how to use it what it does but so Kali
Linux is a distribution full of useful
tools and it it you know for a base OS
it's fantastic
and this is why so many people in the
industry just download this install it
and they're ready to go you know we
talked about in a previous video how
there are other OS Azure there are
people out there that like to just do
their their base install and you can see
that there's bloat layer here if you
want to call it that right like there's
forensic tools and maybe you'll never do
any forensics in your life and you don't
need all this installed in your system
so if you're a type of person that is
you know it doesn't want this extra
stuff this extra software on your system
okay then maybe you do start moving
towards that custom build eventually in
your career you say hey I want I want to
learn all these things first and then
once I learned what tools I really like
then maybe you moved to your own
distribution that you create yourself
and you spin that up every time instead
of having all these tools built in but
as a base OS as something that you can
learn from and start with this is why
I've chosen Kali and this is why we're
gonna learn it today so let's go ahead
from here what we're gonna do is we're
gonna dive right into the terminal so
let's just open this terminal and then
we're gonna fullscreen it and move on to
the next video so from here on out what
we're gonna be doing is we're gonna be
living in this terminal I'm going to
back away from the graphical side of
things and really just get your hands
dirty in the terminal make you feel
comfortable if you've never used Linux
before this is perfect for you so I'm
gonna give you the the pentester
perspective on why we're doing a lot of
these things some of these commands are
going to be the same commands regardless
if it's on a Kali Linux machine or if
it's on another distribution of Linux so
you'll be able to take a lot of these
commands and just use Linux and another
system as well so if you're interested
in pen testing if you're interested in
Linux this is where we really get into
the meat of the course and it should get
interesting for you so I will catch you
over the next video when we're gonna
start talking about how to navigate the
file system and get comfortable with
that all right on to navigating the file
system so first let's talk about some of
the commands we're going to learn today
so we're gonna learn about PWD which is
present working directory we're gonna
learn about CD which is how we change
directories we're gonna learn about LS
which is going to be listing the files
in a folder or in a directory and we're
also going to talk about how to find
some hidden folders with LS we'll talk
about how to make a directory and to
remove a directory we're going to talk
about copying removing moving and
locating files we'll talk about
something called update DB and how that
pertains to locating files we'll talk
about the password and how to change our
password and we'll talk about an
important command called man so by the
end of this first lesson you should be
pretty comfortable with all of these
commands it may seem a little daunting
but they all kind of play in with each
other again please make sure to take
notes you've got cherry tree built in
you can also use keep note or even just
a notepad in front of you that'll help
with the experience and also maybe
watching the video more than once will
help with the experience as well so
let's go ahead and dive right into the
command line so now our first lesson in
Linux terminology is going to be
navigating the filesystem so if you're a
Windows user you're used to navigating
your filesystem probably through folders
through a GUI so a graphical user
interface well in Linux we can do that
but the majority of time we're going to
live in this terminal here so we really
need to know how to get around so the
first thing we can do here is we can say
hey where are we at
and that's PWD so that stands for
present working directory so you type
that in you hit enter and it says okay
we're in the root folder so we know that
we're in the root folder but how do we
get out of the root folder we can use a
command called
CD and that stands for change directory
so if we want to change directory
backwards we just type in two dots here
and now we can say ok where we are
so we're in a slash so we're just in a
home folder here or just they are
generic slash folder right so what we
can do is well how do we know can we go
backwards from here let's keep trying so
we do PWD again no we can this is our
base folder right so you have to think
of this as the the lowest you can go so
now how do we move around how do we know
how to go forwards again well we don't
know what's in our directories right so
we're sitting in this the slash folder
and how do we look around so there's a
command called LS that lists everything
that's in the folder so if we say LS we
kind of see this color-coordinated here
and the color coordination it just
depends on if it's a folder if the
folders read/write you know there's
permission settings which we're going to
get into later but the majority of these
here are folders okay well we know we
just came out of route so we can go back
into route now how do we do that so we
can say change directory route and we
can actually hit tab to autocomplete I
don't know if you caught that but
there's no are any folder besides route
so that our I can just hit tab and it
should type it out for me oh I lied
there is a run in here somewhere but
it's hidden we're gonna cover that soon
as well so our Oh hit tab autocomplete
can change directory into route so let's
LS and route and see what's in here okay
this is more like our home folder right
so we've got desktop documents downloads
this is kind of what applies to the root
user so what if we're sitting in this
root folder here and we wanted to access
instead this Etsy folder well could we
do the same Etsy command here well I'm
hitting tab and nothing's happening well
because Etsy doesn't belong in this area
right but if we put a forward slash in
front of it because this is the base and
then we hit Etsy they
now we can navigate to the Etsy folder
and we can actually double tab and see
what's all in the Etsy folder like an LS
say no another way to do that is if we
wanted to LS what's in the Etsy folder
without navigating to it we get this
type ls' Etsy and you can see everything
that's in here so there's some some
tricks that we can do right so we don't
have to actually navigate to the folder
to know what's in there
again if we LS and we want to know
what's sitting in videos or even let's
say what's sitting in desktop for our
folder well if we start typing desktop
and hit tab we can't do that either
because everything in Linux is case
sensitive so if we start typing desktop
and then hit tab now we can LS and see
what's in there so our vmware came with
a couple of shell scripts here that are
automatically placed on our desktop if
we wanted to confirm that you can see
that they're both right here so as of
right now we are just sitting in our
route home folder and we know how to
navigate around so if we wanted to go to
desktop we could we could hit LS now and
see what's in there if we wanted to go
backwards we could okay now we're back
in our our root folder and you can also
tell where you're at your present
working directory sits right here right
so this little a tilde is actually your
home folder and you can see that we're
in desktop so if we wanted to go back
into our desktop instead of typing say
you wanted to go to music from your
desktop instead of going route music
which will work you could also just say
I want to go music and that'll put you
there as well and notice you don't need
the leading forward slash when you use
the ax tilde so just some couple
interesting trick so that you'll kind of
pick up along the way
tab is definitely gonna be your best
friend if you run into something with
multiple options say you're trying to CD
and you say I want to go my desktop and
you're tabbing it's not working you can
hit double tab and then it'll show you
okay well there's
desktop documents downloads those are
your three options that start with a D
so now you kind of have an idea as to
how to kind of move around but let's do
a little bit more so what if we want to
make our own folder well there's
something called make directory mkdir so
if we say make directory and we'll say
I'm just gonna use my name Heat it's now
hopefully LS we can see that this heat
folder is now here we can go into the
heat folder and there should be nothing
in it right so we can go back and we can
also get rid of the heat folder remove
directory Heath if it LS again it's gone
so now what else can we do well we can
also look for hidden folders so we can
say LS and - la and we can look for
hidden files and folders here remember
the color coordination so this dot cache
right that in theory is a hidden folder
so if we say CD cache we can go into
there we LS and there's actually some
some information in there but when you
saw it originally you didn't see that
we're going to cover more on this I just
kind of want to show you that trick as
you see over on the left side there's
file permissions and properties so be
aware that just because it looks like
something's not there doesn't mean it's
not there it might just actually be
hidden similar to Windows where you have
hidden files and folders so just a quick
trick to show you that so another thing
we can do so let's go back and don't
worry about what I'm doing here you're
going to cover these commands in a
little bit I'm just gonna echo hi and
we're gonna put that in a test dot text
folder so now if we LS you can see that
test dot text is here so if we want to
actually copy this file we can copy this
file to another location so we can say
hey I've got this test text but I
actually want to move it
to downloads and if we go LS to
downloads you could see that test SOT X
is actually sitting in there and if we
wanted to remove it we can just say
remove from downloads or test that text
actually sorry remove downloads test X
we don't have to transition into that
directory if we don't want to so another
trick say we want to see now that it's
gone and we want to LS but we want to
keep typing this out if you hit the up
arrow now you can just see your old
commands so if you keep typing a command
over and over you can see what's going
on so LS shows that there's nothing in
downloads now we were able to
successfully remove that file so another
thing that we can do is we can actually
move so say we wanted to move test text
and we wanted to put that into downloads
okay now if we LS test text is now gone
from this folder because we've moved it
we haven't made a copy we've actually
physically moved it away so now if we LS
actually let's just tab up you can see
that test text is now in there and I'm
going to remove that here okay and now
the last thing I want to show you is the
locate feature so if we wanted to locate
a file say I wanted to locate Bosch
let's see so we're looking for a file
and we're gonna get more specific along
the way but if you type in locate you
can kind of look through a system to see
if you can find it now I'm looking for
say any type of bin bash or bin our bash
that's fine that's really what I wanted
but it shows you everything with bash in
it now this might not work right away
what you might need to do is update the
database so you type in update DB it
updates everything for you and then you
can use locate again so it has to build
that database of the information that
it's finding in order to locate what
you're searching for so make sure that
you use update DB sort of frequently
okay so two more things I want to show
you and then we'll close out this video
and move on to the next one so an
important thing you want to do with your
new account is we're using a default
password and that's not very secure so
to change a password for our user we can
just type in PA sswd and
now it's going to ask us for do password
so instead of using tor we can use
something else I'm going to type in the
very secure password as my password for
an example here but if you plan on using
this machine for future reference you
can type in a secure password and kind
of keep it so lastly I want to show you
is something called man so man pages man
pages are your instructions for any
command that you're running most
commands come with a man page so let's
say we want to look at LS we can say man
LS and then it's going to give us all
this information here about LS so if you
see it says LS is list directory
contents awesome and then it gives you
what options we can do well we can do a
- a for all which you saw earlier and
you can kind of scroll through here and
just see exactly what it has to offer
and that's kind of it so when you go
through here you can kind of you know if
you're struggling to like you know
there's a command in there but you're
not sure exactly what the command is you
can type in man and search it and
sometimes you can do LS I don't know if
this is going to work but - Josh help
and you get some information as well it
doesn't provide you the full man pages
but it provides you something pretty
close so that's kind of just your way
around if you ever get stuck something
to look for okay so that's it for this
lesson next we're gonna move on to users
and privileges how to add users and how
to how to change some pseudos and some
modifications to our file permissions so
until next time my name is Heath Adams
and I thank you for joining me alright
now let's talk about users and their
privileges
so what are we going to learn in this
lesson we'll do a quick user privilege
overview from there we're going to talk
about the chmod command which is the
change mode command that's going to let
us change the permissions on a file or
directory we're also going to talk about
how we're going to add a user with the
add user command from there we're going
to take a look at a couple of important
files one is the Etsy password file and
the other is the Etsy shadow file so the
Etsy password file is not actually where
the passwords are stored on a machine
that is the Etsy shadow file which
stores the hashes but the Etsy password
file does store it where the users what
users are on the machine and you can
correlate that to the shadow file so
we'll talk about those in more detail
and their importance to pen testing very
very important and then we're going to
talk about su which is the switch user
command and finally we'll talk about
sudo which is a command that allows you
to elevate your privileges on a Linux
machine so let's go ahead and dive right
into our lesson ok so now we're going to
cover users and privileges so in the
last video we touched a little bit on
privileges with our LS la and we touched
a little bit on users by changing the
password of our root account so now
we'll cover a few more commands
regarding those so if we look again at
LS la you could see all this crazy
jumbled wordage over here right so it
actually means something so we look at
the first line here if we see a dash
like this a hyphen that means with the
file if we see a de that means it's
actually a directory and then you see
our W and X so our W and X actually
means read/write/execute
it's the permission settings that this
particular group has now there are three
groups here there's the first second and
then your third right here right so your
first
right here is the owner of the file so
it looks like the owner of the file has
full read/write execution right and then
the next set of three here is actually
the permissions for the members of the
group that owned the file so this is a
group ownership as opposed to actual
ownership here so for the people that
are in the group that has access to this
file they can only read and execute they
can't write to it now for the last one
this is just all their users so any
common user here you can actually just
read and execute they can't write the
document so that comes into play
especially when we get into penetration
testing because with penetration testing
we're looking to have full access right
so we're always going to be looking for
that folder that has full read/write
typically if we look at temp that's our
temp folder a lot of times you see the
temp folder has full read/write/execute
so when we're doing penetration testing
we're trying to upload some sort of
exploit we might actually upload it into
the temp folder because that's where we
can execute those those files however we
could also be looking for other full
read/write/execute files where we need
to modify them and give us root access
to a system so it's all about insecure
configurations and we're going to cover
that more once we get into the actual
penetration testing part of the course
so for the linux essentials part of the
course all we need to worry about is
these file permissions another important
feature of that is if we were to create
a script our scripts not gonna be able
to run until it has full access so how
do we change access here so let's make a
file I'm just going to make will just
echo another text document right so
we'll just say hello and actually I type
that in backwards so hello and we'll
call it hello text so if we LS here by
default we only have read write and then
read access for everybody else meaning
if we wanted to read it we could say cat
which we're going to get into later cat
hello Tex it just says hello so what can
we do here well we can use something
called change mode in changing mode is
CH LOD and we have a couple options here
so we can do a plus right and we could
say well we want read write execute or
we just want execute but another way I
like doing it is you have a number
feature so the one you really need to
know is all sevens sevens gives you full
rewrite access across the board so if we
say chmod 777 hello dot text now we LS
la and you notice that hello dot Tex
turns green that means it is full
rewrite and here you go we've got the
dash here saying it's a file and we got
read write execute across the board so
this is how we change file permissions
you don't need to necessarily know about
the other numbers in terms of
penetration testing it becomes more in
terms of configuration and security
management of files if you were to get
down that path so to stay on the easiest
path just remember 777 or + X will work
as well so changing the mode is is
critical and we're going to cover it
time and time again throughout the
course once we get a little bit deeper
so a couple more things we need to talk
about say we wanted to add a new user
well there's a feature called add user
so we say add user and one or two names
is allowed so we need to add user say
John ok so it made something for John
let's give him a password give them a
password again and we'll just hit enter
for the defaults it's all correct ok so
we now have a user named John and we can
confirm that we can actually cat the at
the password file here and you see down
at the very bottom we have this user
John so this Etsy password file you're
going to become very familiar with
because it shows you all the users now
this will there's a lot of times where
you're doing penetration testing you're
gonna have access to this Etsy passer
file because it doesn't provide the
password anymore
it used to a long time ago passwords are
now in the shadow file so you actually
have a little bit of access and
information disclosure here at the hands
of poor configuration so you see that
I've created a user John well that gives
us a little bit for information say
there's SSH on a machine or something
else we can use that username of John to
try to break into the machine so we'll
cover that again later
but if we wanted to see what the SC
shadow file looks like
now we come in here and you've got these
these jumbled stuff here right so it's
just a hashing format so what we're
doing is we can actually use a tool like
hash cat to break this down and crack
these passwords now a password of
password will be very easy but just know
that if you have access to the SC shadow
file you have a good chance of cracking
a password depending on your
capabilities and depending on the
strength of the password that'll allow
you access to a machine so something to
think about there ok so now we have our
user John let's go ahead and switch to
him so we can use something called su
which stands for switch user and we'll
say switch user John ok so it
automatically gave us John here let's
see if we could switch back to root ok
we can't just switch back to root
because we need roots password right so
we can type in password and that works
but if we didn't know the password then
we'd be stuck on John we are able to
access John because we were already root
so this comes into play in terms of
users so let's go back to John here now
if your user you have to be able to do
certain things you need permission to do
certain things
should say right so root has full access
and permission to do everything but John
we just created John John doesn't have
any sort of access so if we wanted to if
we wanted to change the password say we
want to change the password for for rude
I can't modify the password information
because I don't have that kind of access
now there is something called the sudo
which would provide John that access if
we gave it to him so it's called a
pseudo verse file and basically anybody
in that sudoers file can change
permissions given if they are a pseudo
user right so we would type in sudo
password root and it's going to ask for
the password for John but you're gonna
notice hey John's not in the pseudo or
is file John can't do this so John has
base permissions right and we're gonna
counter that a lot of times in
penetration testing where if we get in
we'll get something called lower
privilege and we'll get an account like
John and we're gonna try to escalate in
the root but we just can't do it you
know the chances of doing a doing that
and having a John in a pseudo horse file
is just not high it's possible but it's
not likely so for now just know that if
you want a user other than root to have
access to file permissions you need to
have them in the su doors file that
becomes useful too and penetration
testing because you can look at the
sewers file if you have access to see
what users have sudo privileges okay so
that is it for this lesson in the next
lesson we're going to be covering
Network commands and moving on gradually
towards scripting so let's go ahead and
get there and I will see when we get
over there alright so now we're going to
be covering common network commands
before we dive into the commands we're
gonna learn I'm gonna go on a tiny bit
of a rant here so if you are not
familiar with networking now is the time
to become familiar with networking there
are two things I think that a person
needs before they really can dive into
pen testing and that is Linux experience
which you are gaining some linux
experience now because most pen testing
is done
Linux and the other thing is to have a
good network foundation so if you're
looking at these commands here and I say
ifconfig which if you're a Windows user
and you hear IP config you know what
that is okay that's basically the same
thing if you know what ping is if you
know what ARP is netstat route those
should all be pretty familiar where you
can guess what those are if you do not
know what these commands are you might
want to brush up on your networking as
well because the better you are and
networking the better you're gonna be
when it comes to pen testing because
you're gonna have to navigate around
networks you're gonna have to understand
where you are at in a network your going
to need it for basic troubleshooting as
well so just to understand these
commands to be very important but what
we're gonna be doing here is we're going
to be taking common Network commands
that we're gonna be running as a pen
tester and we're just gonna apply those
to their version in Linux some of these
may be familiar to you some may be new
to you but we're talking here ifconfig
which is just going to show us some
information very similar to IP config in
Windows where we'll see our ipv4 ipv6 if
we have it information our MAC address
things along those lines our subnet mask
etc the iw config is the wireless
adapter version of that ping is a ping
command where we talk over ICMP and we
try to communicate to another machine to
see if it's alive and responding back to
us we've got the ARP command which just
maps IP addresses to MAC addresses and
we've got netstat which is just a
command line tool that's going to allow
us to display all connections and
listening ports and then finally we've
got route which displays our routing
table so we'll go ahead and take a
little bit of a deep dive into those in
this next lesson and hopefully this is a
refresher for you so again if not then
you should be looking into some
networking studies as well okay so let's
go ahead and dive right in okay
so now let's cover network commands so
the first command I want to cover is
ifconfig so you may be familiar with the
Windows version of this which is IP
config and they pretty much do the same
thing so it shows you here your
different interface types and the IP
address associated with them so each 0
here Ethernet 0 has an IP address of
192.168.1 32.16 4 you can see the
netmask the broadcast address and you
can see the MAC address as well and we
also have a loopback address here now if
your machine has a wireless adapter or
at some point you want to do wireless
penetration testing you're going to need
iw config and you should not expect to
see anything on this at the moment
unless you're using a laptop then you
actually might see a configuration down
here for it if you would see something
under iw config you would see like a W
LAN 1 wlan0 something along those lines
ok and another common command that what
you're gonna see is gonna be the ping
command so we can just type in ping and
the address that we're trying to talk to
so for example I'm gonna try to ping my
home router and I get talking back so if
I tried to ping something that wasn't in
my network like a 16.1 you're gonna see
the results change so with ping here
ping is going to be endless until we hit
something like control C to stop it
it'll ping forever so I'm going to hit
control C again and kind of show you the
difference so you see that we attempted
to ping here and we got replies we got
information back well that's good that
means we're talking to the other machine
it says hey are you there it says yeah
I'm there and we try to ping this
machine here but this machine's not
talking back it could mean that the
machine is not on the network or that
the machine is just blocking ICMP
traffic ICMP is a
their word for ping so moving on to the
next command I want to show you ARP so
the best way I like to type in is ARP
with a switch of a and ARP is just going
to show you MAC addresses that it talks
to and the IP address actually I said
that backwards it's going to show you
the IP address it talks to and the MAC
address associated with it so if an IP
address reaches out say 192 168 15.1
talked out to this machine it's gonna
say okay hey who are you it's gonna send
a broadcast message you're Alex and say
who has this IP address and then the IP
address will respond it says hey I do
and this is my MAC address so ARP is
just a way of associating IP addresses
with MAC addresses and once you know
that you can also look at net stat so
net stat - ano is another one of my
favorite commands and this shows you
just the active connections that are
running on your machine so if we scroll
way up and you can just kind of see
what's open and what's talking here
where this really comes in handy on a
penetration test is to see if a machine
is talking to somebody else
same thing with ARP you want to know
what that machine is associated with
and is it talking to something on a port
so this is more just internal right now
but it's still good to know so for
example if I were to open up a Firefox
page and connect out to the Internet
then I went and I did a net stat again I
would see information about that port
being open and and that I am going out
with it so just kind of keep that in
mind these are not commands that you
really need to know in depth right now
networking does come into play when you
are doing penetration testing but we're
gonna cover these commands time and time
and again I just wanted to give you a
very brief introduction to them okay in
the last command that I have for you
today is route so if you type in a route
that's gonna print your routing table in
the routing table is important because
it tells you where your traffic exits
essentially so for this VM my traffic is
exiting on 192 168 1 3 4.0 so any
traffic goes out of this 0 to 0 to 0
that's 0 gateway in this range right so
when it goes out this gateway it's doing
NAT so network address translation and
it's running off my computer so the best
examples aren't here but it's important
to know route as well because there
could be a machine that you're attacking
that has multiple routes so you might
see a 134 and a 1:35 because it has a
dual home NIC the meaning it has two
NICs inside of it so it's actually
talking to a completely different
network that you didn't know existed so
you might have been attacking one
network on the 134 range and then 135
just out there and this computer can
talk to both and until that point you
had no idea and that's the idea of
called pivoting when you switch a
network from one to the other but you're
using a machine so that's it for this
lesson in the next lesson we're gonna
talk about viewing creating and editing
files
okay so viewing creating and editing
files this section sounds exactly like
what it is we're going to talk about how
to view create and edit files mainly
we're just going to be showing how to
create quick text documents but we'll
teach you commands that will allow you
to do further in the future as you will
see as we get further in the course and
get into scripting so let's go ahead and
take a look at some of the commands that
we're going to be learning so some of
the commands that we're gonna learn
we're gonna learn the echo command which
echoes what we write right back out to
the terminal we're going to look at the
cat command which is going to print out
a document for us it's similar to type
in Windows
we'll talk about replacing verse
appending and which which function does
which and how to do it we're going to
talk about the touch command which can
be used to create a file on the fly
we'll talk about Nano which is a text
editor that's built into the terminal
and then we're going to talk about G at
it which is also a text editor but it is
a GUI text editor so we do get a little
bit of GUI in this lesson so let's go
ahead and dive right in okay so this is
my second time recording this video the
first time I forgot to turn my
microphone on and performed for my cat
so she approved of it let's see if you
approve of it the second time around now
that I have a little bit of practice so
we're going to be talking today is we're
talking about viewing creating and
editing files so I've already showed you
the echo command if you recall we used
echo to create a file right we've
created a hello Tex and we can just echo
hello out to the terminal we could say
echo hello and I'll say hello back so
what we can do with echo is we can use
it to write to a file so if we were to
say echo hey and then we write it - hey
dot txt well we can look and see that
hey dot txt is here and you can see my
files from the previous one so I'm
trying to come with more ways of saying
hello but we're going to use hey dot
text here so if we cat hey dot Tex
hey all cat does is print out to the
screen what is in a file it says hey
okay so let's say we want to append cat
or we want to append hey dot txt well we
can tab up here what if we just say hey
again we've got this greater than symbol
here and we're just putting it into the
haida text file well that didn't work we
didn't append it we actually overrode it
so
what if what can we use to actually over
upend this here what we can do is we
could say hey again again right just to
give us something different and we can
add a second greater than symbol here so
now if we cat the file you can see that
we actually append it to the end of it
so this becomes incredibly useful when
we are either adding stuff to a list say
we're gathering IP addresses and we just
want to combine our lists or when we're
creating a series of commands and we're
going to use those commands to send all
at once we're going to cover that later
when we're talking about file transfers
in the penetration testing section where
we use a set of commands like this on a
Windows machine to actually transfer
files via FTP it's just so much easier
than typing them all in one by one we
can create a little document and run the
document so this becomes useful when we
have a series of commands and for other
reasons as well as you'll learn as you
go on in your Linux career so we've
talked about echo and we've talked about
cat so let's talk about some other ways
to create a file we can use something
called touch and to say new file that
tags and if we LS you could see that new
file about Texas here but if we cat new
file there's nothing in there because we
haven't put anything in there yet
so there's a few things that we can do
we could use echo and append the file
right we could also use a tool called
Nano now Nano is a terminal text editor
there are other terminal text editors
like VY and vim I don't prefer those
personally I like Nano the most some
people have their preferences so I
encourage you to play around with any of
them as you wish by and them are the
other two but for this course we're
going to be using Nano so if I say Nano
new file text I could type whatever I
want in here and we're going to be using
Nano a lot to create scripts to create
Python scripts and to edit shell code
as we get into a little bit of exploit
development so I'm gonna hit control X
I'm gonna hit Y for saving and then
we'll save it to new file dot txt if we
cap this
now it says hey I could type whatever I
want in here so that's one way of
editing it another way of editing it is
using a graphical interface so we can
use G at it and say new file and if you
don't like using a terminal you're more
than welcome to use G edit here just
type in a new line here and save it and
I I like using G edit it's a lot cleaner
cuz I can you know highlight and delete
I don't have to use my keyboard and
navigate around like I do in the
terminal so if you have the option to
use G edit for sure but sometimes you're
gonna be on another machine that's not
your own or it's headless and doesn't
have a GUI that you're gonna have to use
now so get comfortable using bolt so we
save this let's go ahead and cat it out
and see what happens
okay you can see that the new line is in
there so really that's the overview that
I wanted to cover so just know that you
can create files pretty much using echo
touch I and actually you can create
files using nano as well if you say Nano
this is new text I'll just say hello
control X save it you LS you can see
this is new Texas right here so you can
use all of these tools in different ways
to create files it's completely up to
you how you want to do it personally
what I'm creating a file I use Nano and
I just create a new shell script Python
script a text document that way you
could also do it using G edit as well so
just know that we're going to be using
these a lot and try to get comfortable
with these and from here we're going to
be moving into controlling Kali services
so we're just gonna briefly talk about
what services you need running on boot
and how to do that alright in this video
we're going to be talking about starting
and stopping kali services let's go
ahead and just take a quick look at the
commands we're going to
so not a lot of commands in this video
only two we're going to talk about the
service command and the system CTL
commands so the service command deals
with services it's going to allow us to
start and stop services on the fly and
the systemctl command is going to allow
us to enable or disable services so that
they load up on boot or do not load up
on boot so let's talk a little bit more
about services and look at how these
commands can be useful for pen testing
all right so let's talk about starting
and stopping services so when we're in
Cali there are a couple different ways
that we can start and stop services and
when I talk about a service I'm talking
about something like a web server or SSH
or maybe a sequel database so when we
cover this video today I'm going to show
you a few different services and how to
start them and stop them I'll show you
how to start them permanently on boot
and we'll talk about which services are
important to keep on boot which services
are important to to start when you feel
like that just starting them or when you
need them etc so let's start with our
first service which is going to be
Apache - now Apache - is a web server so
let's go ahead and do a proof-of-concept
first let's start with a command that we
learned in an earlier video which is
ifconfig I'm gonna grab our ipv4 address
right here
and I just want to copy this I want to
go out to a web browser over here and
we're just gonna paste this address now
you'll notice that it says it's unable
to connect this is expected here we are
not running a web server now let's go
back in here and let's just say service
Apache to start ok looks like it went
through let's go ahead and hit enter
again and now you can see that Apache to
Debbie and default page has been loaded
so what has changed well when we boot
our machine this apache2 service is not
running by default so if we want to run
a web page then we actually have to
start up the service for it to work as
you just saw here now you can see that
if we want to add files or replace files
here well we're going to have to edit
the bar ww HTML folder so if we come out
here and we go into other locations
computer and then we go into our bar
ww HTML you'll see that the index.html
page is here so if we actually wanted to
maybe host a malicious web page and have
it point back to us this is one way we
might do it right here if we want to
serve up some files say we have
something that we want to upload to a
machine that might be malicious or you
know a file that we want to transfer to
somebody else or download on another
computer it doesn't have to be malicious
we could host that file in this folder
here now that is fine this is one way to
do it right you could put your files all
in one location but you know yeah it's
not my favorite way it was my favorite
way when I first got started there is a
much easier way now and I will show you
how to do that so let's go ahead and
type LS you'll see we have no documents
here so I'm just going to echo hello
into hello text and then have that hello
text here now what we can actually do is
we can spin up a web server so we can
just say Python - M for a module and say
simple HTTP server you can auto tab it
and then say 80 for the port Oh 80 is
already in use so let's just give it 80
80 80s and use from the Apache server at
the moment so instead let's look at what
happens so let's just call it out at
8080 and you can see here that I can go
to this hello dot text and actually get
the file I have information in real time
whether or not that file was captured
and overall this
just a webserver that's so easy to spin
up I can put it in the directory that I
wanted to so if I wanted to serve my
desktop folder I would navigate to
desktop and then spin this this Python
module up I don't have to put everything
into a var WW folder and it just makes
life really really simple so just proof
of concept we can do a service Apache to
stop and we can come back and make sure
that that web server has been stopped by
going here
and refreshing now you can see that it's
gone we can CD into something like
downloads we say LS there's nothing in
here so we can tab up a couple times and
just serve up port 80 now because you
can see it's not in use anymore and come
back here refresh you can see there's
nothing in the directory listing because
there's nothing in the folder so this is
just an easy way to spin up a web server
I think it's much easier than Apache -
I'm showing you both because they like
to give alternatives but using Python
moving forward is a great great feature
my challenge to you is to look up how to
spin up a FTP server with Python so I
won't get redundant here I do have
future lessons and other courses that
talk about this but if you want to
challenge yourself to figure out how to
spin up an FTP server that's my
challenge to you there's a module out
there that you can download quite easily
and spin up your own FTP server so let's
go ahead and ctrl C we're going to close
out of this and now let's talk about
spinning up a service permanently so
let's say that we just had the Apache
tube running and then we rebooted the
machine when we reboot our machine
Apache 2 is not going to be online
because we're only doing a service start
it only holds during this session once
we reboot that session is gone that
service is gone so if we want to keep
something online the entire time what we
can do is use systemctl so we can say
system CTL enable or disable if you want
to disable something and for example we
could say SSH now I'm not going to hit
enter here this is just an example well
let's say that we wanted to have an SSH
available on our machine so we can SSH
into it we are opening up SSH for this
feature here ok let's say that we want
to have a server and this is one I do
want you to hit enter in so this is
going to be a database right this is a
PostgreSQL so we're going to say
systemctl enable PostgreSQL
and we have enabled that so now we
reboot this PostgreSQL will load every
single time now why is this important
well this is important because it's
going to allow us to run Metasploit and
have the PostgreSQL database running
when we boot so it doesn't have to take
the extra time to load it if we come
over here and we just click on the
Metasploit framework now PostgreSQL is
working and it says database already
started so it's already configured it's
gonna skip initialization it's going to
go ahead and get right into it so it
just saves us a little bit of time mat
is full you can take some time to to run
and I think that if you continue on I
know if you continue on with being a pen
tester you're definitely going to be
using Metasploit quite a bit so this is
just one feature that if you're gonna be
using it it doesn't hurt to have it
enabled on your system boot now if you
feel that you want to have Apache to on
boot you can go ahead and do the same
thing with the system enable systemctl
enable but the only one that I recommend
putting on is this system CTL PostgreSQL
okay so that is it for this video in the
next video we're going to be talking
about installing how to install things
from github and how to install using
apt-get so let's go ahead and move right
into that video alright welcome to the
pen ultimate video we are going to be
focusing on installing and updating
tools so let's look at our agenda so
what are we going to learn we're gonna
learn how to install updates for Kali so
we're gonna learn how to install updates
using a tool called apt-get and we're
also going to learn how to install tools
using apt-get specifically we're going
to be installing a tool today called git
we're going to be using git than to
clone from a website so sometimes when
we have a tool that we want it's not
always in apt-get it's not in the
repository so we're gonna actually have
to use github and maybe use a tool
called git to download tools or other
items from github but this is just going
to be one example but it's a very very
common example that
you may have to do as a pen tester so
let's dive in and take a look at how we
can use these commands to install tools
and update tools okay so one of the
important things you need to know is how
to not only install files on your
computer but also how to install updates
on your computer so for Kali since this
is a debian base we're going to use
something called apt-get and the first
thing I'm going to show you is how to
install updates so the common way to do
this if you don't use the GUI and you
want to use terminal is apt-get update
and then we'll do and half get upgrade
let's go ahead and just hit enter on
this and let's explain what it's doing
so the first command here is saying
apt-get update so what we're doing is
we're looking through packages now these
packages are predefined their
repositories and what it does is it says
ok I'm going to check packages here for
updates and it went through
looks like they use archived Linux due
to ITU they check these packages here
and they update the packages and then
once they update the packages they run
this command so basically the and
command is your gonna do something as
well right so first we're gonna update
and then we're going to upgrade so based
on what's in these packages it's gonna
say ok well we know the following
packages were automatically installed
and no longer required so all these
things right here they're gonna be
removed and then the following packages
have been kept back ok they're fine
they're not going to uninstall those and
then we have the following packages that
are gonna be upgraded ok so it's a long
list that needs updating and then you
come in here and you say ok well it
needs 252 megabytes of additional disk
space to continue you could hit enter
for yes and they'll automatically start
upgrading so if you want to update your
machine to its newest and best form you
can go ahead and do that I'm
go ahead and just hit no on this guy
okay and now it's also important to know
how to install files so I'm going to
show you two different ways one way is
through apt-get similar to what we just
did and the other way is going to be
through git itself so let's go ahead and
install git we're going to use apt-get
to install git so it'll look something
like this we'll just say apt-get install
git and we'll hit yes on this and
another way to do this is to add a dash
Y at the end of this so you'd say app -
git install git - y and that'll
automatically say yes if you just want
to accept whatever is coming out for you
you go ahead and just hit YES on that
and it may take a minute for these to
install while this is installing let's
go ahead and talk about what get does so
git works with github so when we talk
about github we're talking about a lot
of people update their projects their
code their frameworks onto github
especially in the penetration testing /
hacking community it's often that you're
gonna find some cool tools that are out
there than are installed on Kali Linux
can't be found through apt-get and you
have to actually download them from
github so it's very important to know
how to use git and it's very very simple
so we're on a page like this
this is Vale framework it's a very
popular tool in penetration testing in
malware analysis as well so say we
wanted to install this well there's a
couple things we could do the first
thing we could do is always read the
directions and see what they recommend
there is a quick install here and if you
look they have a app install veil here
with the - why so that will work or you
can use gits install where you have to
install get first okay and then we do a
git clone and we run the configuration
setup so that's what we're gonna do here
we're going to install veil just for the
fun of it just
you can kind of get used to how to use
github how to use git and go from there
so let's go ahead and just alt-tab back
over it looks like we have it we can
check it by typing git and hitting tab
okay so git is here and we're just going
to hit space we know the command is
clone and while it provides it for us
down here it says hey get cloned copied
this the other place you can do it is
right here where it says clone or
download you just copy this bad boy
right here we'll alt tab back over to
our terminal and just hit paste okay and
this is going to install in the
directory that you choose so I just put
it in this root folder here and actually
our our home folder I should say and
it's installed right here the folder is
Vale right here typically when I install
things I like to put them in the opt
folder so here CD opt but since I went
ahead and downloaded here let's just go
ahead for an example purpose if you do
want to install to opt you're more than
welcome you can move the folder there as
well
so what we're going to do is we're gonna
see the into Vale and then we'll hit LS
now remember there were instructions so
let's go ahead and look at what those
instructions were these instructions
said you're gonna run dot forward slash
config setup that Sh force silence let's
go ahead and just copy this guy we'll
come back in here and we'll hit paste
and it's just going to run out of this
config folder setup that Sh and now it's
installing so we could have easily
installed this with app - git which if
you look look what it's doing it's
actually rolling through the packages
here and it's updating the repositories
right at these packages and then it's
going to go ahead and download what it
needs so it's running apt-get anyway if
you see updating apt it's installing the
dependencies so the easier way the quick
way which you suggested was to do it
through there and it's
right they don't always have the
installed packages in apt-get so that's
why I wanted to show you the github
version of it so you can go ahead and
let this install let's just go ahead and
recap quickly what we just did
so we used we used apt-get update and
upgrade to install updates in our system
we used git clone to be able to download
packages and clone packages off of
github and we used apt-get to be able to
download git itself so that's really it
for this lesson what I do encourage you
to do is go through the man pages of git
and go through the man pages of apt-get
because you're also able to remove
programs update specific programs etc so
this lesson really just wanted to
introduce you to the basics of
downloading an updating for your system
I encourage you to learn how to remove
files as well as a little bit of
homework for yourself so thank you for
joining me and I will catch you over in
the next lesson alright welcome to the
last lesson video so in this video we
are going to be scripting with bash now
this may seem a little overwhelming at
first what we're going to be doing is
building out a ping sweeper script it's
going to be pretty basic and what I want
you to do is maybe just watch this video
once and then the second time through
really try to follow along with it take
notes etc I think first time watched
through you know just to get the
concepts understand what I'm doing and
then the second time really really get
hands-on with it and I think that'll be
probably the best way to learn but if
you have a different learning style
please do go ahead and try that as well
the only thing I could say is don't let
this intimidate you hopefully by the
time the videos over with you will have
a pretty good understanding on a basic
scripting and how scripting can really
be beneficial and improve our timing
improve automation etc so let's go ahead
and quickly talk about some of the
things are going to learn
in this video okay so some of the
commands and items are going to learn
we're going to talk about grep which is
going to allow us to narrow down some
results we're also going to talk about
cut and TR both of those are also going
to help us narrow down some results so
basically we're going to start with a
ping that we're going to send out and
we're going to want to gather
information back that says that ping was
valid so we want to know any computer
that responded to us well how are we
going to do that well we need to
identify what a valid ping looks like
we're going to use grep to to kind of
narrow down a string or a sentence or
something that identifies with a
positive ping and then we're going to
cut out everything we don't want and use
TR as well to cut some things out that
we don't want so we're going to put this
into a script when it's all said and
done and we're also going to be talking
about the usage of for loops and their
importance not only with using them in
this script but how we can use simple
one-liners to do everyday things for us
so I'll show you at the end of the video
how we're going to use like a end map
and use a for loop with n map to run
through an end map script so stay tuned
through the video again if you are a
hands-on learner maybe first time
through you you try hands on but my
recommendation here is to just sit back
watch the video understand what's going
on second time really follow along with
it take notes and get the most that you
can know this lesson so let's go ahead
and get started alright so now we're
going to be covering bash scripting so
the first thing we're going to need to
cover before we get into writing our
scripts is how to narrow down results
and we say narrowing down results what
we're saying is for given a block of
text and we want to extract some
information from that block of text how
are we going to do that so that's what
we're gonna cover in this lesson
okay so let's go ahead and get started
what we're going to be doing today is
narrowing down a ping result so if we
come into here and we need to ping an IP
address within our system so I'm going
to be pinging 192.168.1.1 you're going
to see that it returns a 64 bytes from
that address so it looks like we're
getting a response I'm going to hit
control-c here so if you remember from
the networking section we actually get a
response
unlimited until we cancel it right like
we just controlled see here from ping so
there's another thing that we can do if
we only want to send one packet and see
if it's alive or not we can do a dash C
of one so we're just going to do that so
that's a count of one we're sending one
packet over if we set ten it would send
ten packets over if that makes sense
so now what we're going to do is we're
going to put this into a text file so if
you remember from previous video we just
use this little caret here and I'm going
to call this IP dot text okay and if we
cat IP dot text you'll see the same
results there so now what we're going to
want to do is we're going to want to
narrow this down what do I want to
extract from here well I want to extract
this IP address and it'll make more
sense when we get into the scripting
part but what we're going to do is we're
going to get out specifically of this
this IP address from this line now what
we're interested in actually is a
returned IP address that has a valid
response right so if I were to tech or
if I were to enter in here say 15.99 Dov
what it looks like when it doesn't get a
response back it just kind of lingers
and then we hit ctrl C and it says zero
ping statistics right nothing was was
received back so what we see when we get
a response back as we see 64 bytes when
there's no response back we don't have
any bytes so if we're doing a sweep
through a network which we're going
to be doing later we need to be able to
narrow down these results so if we're
sending say 192.168.1.1 all the way
through to 55 and we want to see who
responds back and then take that list
and narrow it down to the IP addresses
which is exactly we're going to be doing
we need to know how to narrow that down
so what we're going to be narrowing down
on specifically is the 64 bytes so let's
tab up a couple times to this cat IP
address and we're going to do a pipe and
the pipe just means we're going to add
an additional command here so the
additional command we're going to do is
called grep grep is going to grab any
line with what you specify so let's
specify 64 bytes and see what happens
see now if you noticed we had all of
these lines before and now what grep is
doing is grep is taking only the lines
that contains 64 bytes so again a valid
response so we have 64 bytes here and we
have achieved a response so what we're
going to do now is we're going to narrow
this down some more okay we've got this
line here but again we're still trying
to extract this IP address so how can we
do that well there is a tool called cut
so if we tap up again we do another pipe
because they're sending a new command
we're gonna say cut and cut syntax looks
like this and I'll explain it once I
type it out here okay so we have cut and
then this - D that's a delimiter so the
delimiter is what we're going to be
cutting on so we're giving a delimiter
of a space meaning here's a space here's
a space here's a space so we're going to
be cutting on these spaces and then we
give a field we say okay what field we
want to retrieve back from this cut okay
we want field four if you look one two
three four and the fourth field is our
IP address so it's gonna say okay I'm
gonna cut on this space I'm gonna cut on
this space I'm gonna cut on this space
and then I'm going to take it right here
now if we identified Phil five we would
be taking this if we identified Phil
three we'd be taking from so let's go
ahead and just hit enter and see what
that looks like okay so now we are
narrowed down even more but there's an
issue here if we were to try to send
this IP address we would have this
little colon here attached on to it and
you can't ping with that IP address so
we're going to be doing a sweep or
narrowing down this list then we're
gonna actually need to remove this guy
here so let's take a look at how we do
that so if we tab up again and again
we're going to add a pipe now we're
going to use a command called TR and TR
just means translate what we're going to
be doing is another delimiter so - D
there and we're going to be taking out
that colon so it should look something
like this if we hit enter now you can
see that that colon has been removed
okay now let's talk about how we can use
this information to write out a script
we're going to start with a basic script
and we can add upon it as we go so I've
gone ahead and written out a script but
we're going to talk about it very slowly
so you can actually look at it and copy
it down so what we're going to do is go
ahead and say G edit and I call this IP
sweep SH so go ahead and do the same or
something similar and hit enter so let's
take a look at this script so at the
very top here we have to declare what
we're doing so we're going to give a
hash bang and we do this with any
scripting language so if we this or
Python we'd be entering Python here but
this is bash so we're going to be doing
a forward slash bin forward slash bash
that declares that we're running a bash
script and the dot sh also indicates
that were running a bash script so I
want you to ignore this line here in
this line here for now let's talk about
this line this should look very very
familiar so what we're doing in this
line we are saying we're gonna ping with
a count of 1 which we talked about and
then we're gonna do something here we've
got a dollar sign 1 and a dollar sign IP
let's just ignore that for now okay so
we're going to go ahead and do the rest
that should look familiar
we're gonna say we're going to grab 64
by
we're going to cut the delimiter of a
space feel before and then we're going
to do a translate right and take off
that little bit at the end okay I added
an ampersand here at the end so an
ampersand allows us to do threading so
that's exactly why it's in there if we
didn't we'd have to let the process go
one IP at a time and we'll talk about
that in a second as well so let's talk
about this four line so a four loop is
what we're actually running here and the
loop is saying I want to do an IP
address
we're just declaring a variable here you
can call it whatever you want we're
saying hey for this IP in a sequence of
1 through 254 we're gonna do something
and that do is a pain so what this means
is for IP and if we think about it in
sequence 1 thru 254 what it's saying is
1 2 3 4 all the way up to 254 ok so
think about it this way if we say 4 1 in
this ping sweep we're gonna do that
right so we're gonna say 4 1 4 2 4 3 all
the way through 254 that's what this
loop is doing so it's a very very simple
loop now IP is replaced down here at the
very end
now we're also calling out this dollar
sign 1
now this dollar sign one is user input
so we're gonna actually do something
this is called IP sweep right so we're
gonna have to call out this IP sweep
something like this dot SH and then
we're gonna have to give out some
information it's going to request
information if we don't provide it it
won't know how to ping so what we're
gonna do is we're gonna say the first
three octets of our home network so if
yours is 192.168.1 like mine is then you
just enter 192.168.1 now we could also
for simplicity just hard code this so we
can say 192.168.1.2
it would be fine we don't have to build
this in the only reason we're not hard
coding it is because you can do multiple
pink sleeves this can be a pink sleep
script for you in the future if you're
on a different network or you just want
to write something out really quick
dollar sign one works perfect but if you
want to leave it a hard-coded like this
it'll also work so let's go ahead and
just delete this out I'm going to put
this into dollar sign one again
to have a proof of concept and then we
are going to run this so all we do here
at the end is declare done if we didn't
run this with an ampersand here we would
have to add a semicolon similar to this
but because we are having an ampersand
we can actually get rid of that and just
put that back just for some syntax
clarity here okay so let's go ahead and
save this and remember for my lesson
we're going to have to change the mode
of our script because it's not
executable by default so we're going to
do a plus X here and then we're gonna
call out IP sleep Sh
we can LS and make sure it's green
here's IP sleepy Sh and then we'll do a
dot /ip sweep to SH and I'm not going to
enter anything in I just want to show up
with a concept so see it ran through
every single number here in threading
and name or service not know because we
didn't provide an IP address so what we
can do here is we need to provide that
IP address one six eight dot one hit
enter okay and it pulls back some
information so what we can do with this
information let's write this out to a
file so let's just call this IP list dot
text something like this okay it's done
now let's just cat out the IP list text
okay now we have an IP list of the IPS
in our network that we just swept right
and we can use this information later on
but before we go into that I do want to
go back and just improve our script a
very very tiny bit so let's go ahead and
just tab up a couple times so we get to
our G edit
and let me show you how we can improve
this script it doesn't have to be overly
complicated what we can do is we can say
something like this we can come in here
and give an if statement so an if is
conditional right we're going to say if
this exists then do something and if it
doesn't exist do something else so we're
going to say if dollar sign one is equal
to nothing we're just going to give it
blank space here and then we're going to
say then we want to do something so what
are we going to do we can echo out
something similar - you forgot an IP
address and then echo out what you need
to do like syntax dot slash ping sweet
or IP sweet is what we call this IP
sweep that Sh and then IP or we can even
write it out an example right
like something like that so that way our
user if they're using it we wrote this
for somebody else they know what we're
talking about and at the very end we
just need to write if backwards we'll
put a Fi
so what this is saying is if this is not
then echo here right we're gonna echo
these and then we need to add one other
thing here which is it else let's go
ahead and hit enter just to space it out
a little bit so if we have no dollar
sign one declared right if we have
nothing entered in we're gonna say echo
you forgot an IP address and syntax here
if we do have something in dollar sign
one okay well we're gonna do something
else we're gonna do our ping sleep and
that's it
so this is very similar and modified
from Georgia Weidman's that I've got a
long time ago so full credit goes to her
for this little script it was very very
easy to learn and it's also very easy to
teach so let's go ahead and just run
this one more time we're gonna say IP
sweep - Sh
and look what happens now it says you
forgot an IP address now we can declare
a number in there or anything and the
scripts not perfect right we're
expecting three octets and we could give
it a one and it's still gonna do
something like that which isn't correct
right so we need to be able to to modify
this down more but that gets really
advanced scripting into declaring that
needs to be three octets and if you
don't provide those then what and that
just gets more advanced so we really
just need to know
hey what we're doing here very basic
script for ourselves and something to
remember
okay so let's clear our screen last
thing I want to show you so we've been
able to write a script out but we can
also do looping in one line and this is
where it becomes kind of fun so we have
this IP list right we did cat IP list X
now let's say we've got this IP list
together and we want to do an nmap scan
on all of these IPs
now we could just say and map and type
in the syntax you want and the IP
address of it for every single one of
these starting to have and let that
happen or you could do something in a
for loop so we can write the same for
loop that we did before we're going to
say for IP and then we're going to do is
we're going to write a dollar sign and
we're going to cat the IP list dot txt
so all it does is it's bringing out this
list that we have here and it's saying
okay for this IP this IP this IP etc
we're going to run through all of these
that's what the loop does right okay
we're gonna do our semi colon and then
we're going to tell it to do something
right so what do we want to do okay
let's run it in map script so we're
gonna say do and map and we'll ping or
we'll do a port port 80 on all these and
we'll say stealth scan that on port 80
and we'll do t-44a
speed and that should be it so then we
can do done like this and let it run
through one at a time we can also do the
ampersand and let it run multiples like
the
we could hit enter and see what that
does but I also forgot one thing here
forgot to declare the IP address so
let's talk about it real quick so we've
got a very very simple one-liner and
you're gonna see one-liners a lot if you
get into ethical hacking and just allows
us to do things quickly and scripted so
we got four IP address in this list so
every IP in this list we're going to
loop through when we do that loop we're
gonna do and map we're gonna do a quick
stealth scan a port 80 T 4 and we're
gonna say declare the IP address if
you're not comfortable to end map that's
okay this is purely an example and
something you will see in your career I
will make a scripting video at some
point for nmap and we'll cover and map
more in detail so let's go ahead and
just hit enter okay I messed up my
syntax so what's going on okay so for IP
in just got deleted for IP and cat IP
list let's try this one more time okay
so we just did all these scans seven
scans at once and what we did is you see
these are the processes that are
starting so it started up eight
processes actually not seven and it's
just running through this list doing the
scans and we're gonna go ahead and just
kind of look at it so it says okay on
1.74 is 80 open it's open okay and then
on 254 is 80 open its open and then you
see filter down here or it's not running
filtered filtered same thing so we can
hit control C or hit enter if we're done
and that's pretty much it so what we
just did is we ran AMF scans at one time
instead of having to copy and paste
these so there's just a little bit of
what scripting can do it does get more
advanced but to be able to know a
one-line for loop is really really
important if you go into penetration
testing and it's just important in basic
bash scripting as well so that's really
it for this lesson and that's really it
for this course so I hope you really
learned something from this course if
you did find it valuable please do share
it with others please subscribe if you
haven't please do like the video
word of mouth is the best thing for me
it helps me grow my channel and helps me
give content back to you as I get more
feedback and I grow as a channel so I'm
looking to do more courses in the future
and appreciate you taking time with me
if you like this course and you want to
chat with me check the descriptions down
below I've got a disc or channel we've
got quite a few people in there and I've
also got a Twitter if you want to hit me
up there lastly I do have a patreon if
you felt like this course is valuable
and you would like to support me any
dollar amount goes a long way for me
recording equipment recording software
all that's very expensive and the time
spent on this is also very detailed long
hours so if you want to support me or or
anything a like subscribe etc it goes a
long way I appreciate you taking the
time to watch this course and until the
next one thank you so much for joining
me
alright and now some bonus material so
I'm adding in some additional resources
these are for those of you that want to
continue on you've learned the Linux now
and you're like hey I really want to be
a pen tester I think this is for me I'm
gonna provide you a whole lot of
different resources here so take notes
these are some of the best resources I
can think of for those wanting to get
into the field I'll briefly cover each
of them and then leave you at it to do
your own research and hopefully see you
in the field someday as a pen tester so
let's take a look at some of these
resources
okay so first resource is a shameless
self-promotion and I only do this
because I do think that I'm a valuable
resource I'm trying not to be biased
here but I've got some good good stuff
that's completely free if you are
interested in it so if you come to
youtube.com slash see slash the cyber
mentor you can come to my page here and
you can check out all the videos I have
one video is a day in the life of an
ethical hacker so if you want to know
what it's like to be an ethical hacker
if you're still not sure if this is the
field for you this might be a video for
you to view it talks about the day in
and day out stuff that you might do or
kind of assess
work you might be asked to do and what's
really like to be a an ethical hacker on
top of that I've got another video on
cyber career paths about penetration
testing and ethical hacking so if you're
looking to get into the field and you
want to become a pen tester or ethical
hacker and you're not quite sure where
to go this is probably the better video
for you it kind of talks about all the
knowledge that you'll need for a junior
perspective and really the knowledge
that you'll need to be successful in the
field including certifications etc so if
you're watching this video as an
additional resource this would probably
be additional resource part 2 is a good
way to call it this is the one like
really detail on penetration testing and
ethical hacking on top of that over here
I've got playlists so if you come into
the playlist I've got a few courses most
importantly is our zero to hero course
so if we come to the cyber mentor comm
and you go to courses over here and you
go to zero to hero pentesting you can
find more information on the syllabus so
I put it into lesson plan as well here
but there are let's see eleven episodes
we start with Linux kind of like you've
already learned note keeping some
introduction we do Python for two weeks
we do information-gathering ascent recon
scanning enumeration exploitation we do
internal attacks as well so we'll build
out an Active Directory lab and we'll
learn how to do these internal attacks
that aren't really taught in a lot of
courses and then we'll end it with some
file transfers maintaining access etc
report writing as well and career advice
so this is like my complete course it's
called zero to hero to take somebody
from from a complete zero and bring them
into a hero where they can start doing
some pen testing on their own so again
if your interest in that course you can
come to my website and check it out with
the lessons plan you can just click in
the tab and play the video or on my
youtube channel you can click right on
the playlist and play it from there as
well so leaving the shameless
self-promotion let me talk about some
more cheap alternatives hack
is a great great alternative if you're
just getting started so for hack the box
what it is is it's a series of
vulnerable machines so you could think
of it almost like a game so if you want
to do some hacking this is a great place
to just start practicing and learning
the ropes what we can do is like say we
could pick something on the easy side
you want to look for something like
that's more green right on the left
because that shows easy you would pick a
box like this you would scan against it
and you know if you don't know I'm
talking about that's fine but you would
scan against it and try to find
vulnerabilities and hack it so a really
really great website if you have the VIP
they're starting to move it it's in beta
right now but they have 20 boxes that
you can attack on active side and 20 in
the VIP but to the nice thing about the
VIP is they're about to open up all 97
that I've been retired so they retire
one every week and they bring a new one
in so you gain access it's like $13 a
month this is free completely for your
platform if you don't want it but this
is 13 bucks a month for the VIP access
and you can come in here and do some of
these machines that are super duper easy
and if you click into them they'll have
write-ups for them and they'll also have
video walkthroughs for a lot of these
machines so that's a really really great
stuff right if you have no idea what
you're doing this is a great place to
start because these retired boxes are
boxes that have already been done you
can watch how somebody else did them you
can learn their methodology and this is
really good for just getting the basics
down and understanding you know some
basic hacking same thing here with the
virtual hacking labs it's very similar
they've got a labs they've got a course
and they've got different pricing so you
can try these out if you're interested
in them so they are you know just
alternatives to just practice online
then you've got Voland hub as well
you'll have to search through this and
try to find something that's like
beginner level or Google online which
which are realistic boxes or what what
are good boxes on Bolin hub they've all
had basically you just download the
VMware file and you play it on VMware
and you try to attack the the machine so
you download a machine you try to attack
it and these are intentionally
vulnerable machines all of these right
here on these top
so let's say that that's not really
where you want to start you think maybe
you could use a little bit more
hand-holding and you like a
certification to come behind it I'm
going to show you the top three in my
order that I think for pen testing at
least at a beginner to mid to your level
what the top three are so allure and
security gets number one slot in my mind
if you come into here and you go onto
certifications so they've got a couple
different ones the ECP PT or actually
let's go to courses so the penetration
testing student and the penetration
testing professional the student is for
the beginner the professionals a little
bit more advanced it leaves off for the
beginner ends so if we come in the
student you can see some of the things
that you'll learn so they've got you
know it talks about the preliminary
skills that you might need and teaches
you those it's got some programming and
then just the basics of penetration
testing but it gives you an idea what
it's like on top of that this PTP course
they have is like more in depth more
advanced you start getting into assembly
language and buffer overflows you get
into network pen testing some powershell
linux web app Wi-Fi some ruby four
Metasploit so i think this is really
well-rounded really up-to-date the
downside of this course is that it's not
it's not really well known on the HR
side of things so and then the pricing
can get a little expensive on the elite
side right now it's $1,600 the cheapest
is the 1200 I would at least get the
middle tier but as of right now they're
offering that pts and the PTP if you buy
the PTP they give you the pts for free
but that won't be going on much longer
but you can always hold out for deals
like this as well another resource in a
very very well known resource probably
the best certification in terms of being
known is the OS CP so it starts out at
eight hundred bucks as you can see here
you're probably going to spend more
money than that because that's just 30
days so the nice thing about this is it
comes with labs there's a certain amount
of machines in there that you can try to
hack against sort of like a hack the box
but there's an
so you can you notice attack whatever
you feel like and try to navigate your
way through the network and then when
you are done and you want to test for
the certification you have to actually
hack in an environment of misete number
of machines you have to hack against and
you have to be successful in hacking
those machines to get your certification
so it's considered one of the more
difficult certifications out there to
achieve and you'll see it come up a lot
of times in HR or job applications that
they want this osep so this is something
to look into and consider as well the
cost isn't as bad as the elearn but the
con here is that office and security
courses haven't been updated in five or
so years so you really need to you know
it's kind of the the best of both worlds
if you were able to do both but this one
will get you into more doors this one
will get you a little bit more current
but there are plenty of resources out
there all these tabs I've shown you that
you don't have to spend a ton of money
to get this stuff these are more things
that if you want that certification you
want that that coursework that knowledge
these are great resources all three of
these so last is the G pen now the G pen
is just an exam by itself at seventeen
hundred dollars it is by sans right so
this is showing GE IAC you actually have
to take the corresponding sans course
that goes with it and that course is
upwards of $6,000 so unless you can get
a employer to pay for this and
certification probably not the best but
the thing that I like about sans is that
it stays up to date they are constantly
updating their courses and that they
look good on a resume it's one of those
really high tier high level
certifications and the exam from what I
hear is actually pretty good it's not a
practical exam but it's a fairly good
exam and the nice thing I didn't mention
elearn security is also practical so
this OS CP is practical the ealer and
security exams practical you have to
hack your way through to two pass and
write a report as well this one is a
multiple-choice exam I do believe so
these are
three certifications that you can look
into if you're wanting to go down that
route I would start with the pts if you
can it's dirt cheap you know if I have
to make a recommendation just to make
sure that you're you're really
interested in this if you know for sure
and you want to do that pts PGP combo
this might be a good choice here but
other than that I mean the free
resources like I've got my channel
there's a ton of videos the zero two
here of course is like at least twenty
to thirty hours of material hack the Box
you'll spend a lot of time on there's
plenty of write-ups if you just google
like honestly if we go in here and we
say like apocalypse here if you say that
and you google at with write-up you're
gonna find the right up for this or
you'll find a video for this or some
kind of walkthrough right so you just
want to look through these and try to
try it on your own and then go back and
then watch the write-up and see how you
could have improved if you've got
through it or where you can improve an
enumeration or whatever is you need to
to get better to actually succeed the
next time you try attacking these
machines so that is it you have reached
the end of this course and the end of
the bonus material if you need anything
I provided my contact info again in the
beginning you know I'm at the cyber
mentor on Twitter you can reach me on
youtube as well and I really do thank
you for joining me I look forward to
seeing many of you take the next step
from this Linux if you made it this far
you've already gotten through the
beginner Linux and that's awesome I hope
you take this next step and that you are
intrigued by penetration testing because
we need more people in the field so I
look forward to seeing you guys and
girls come through and hopefully I'll
work with some of you someday so until
next time my name is Heath Adams and I
thank you for joining me